is your company equipped to deal with
software development and delivery
as it adopts technologies like
containers hybrid cloud or even
multi-cloud
yes no maybe well keep watching as we
unwrap the modern ci cd
with and those
[Music]
i'm priyanka vergaria and welcome to
anthos 101
in this episode we're talking about all
things cicd
on your journey to container adoption
across hybrid and multi-cloud
environments
it is important to think seriously about
continuous integration and continuous
delivery
oftentimes you will see operations teams
getting bigger
security best practices tougher to
enforce over
more environments and reliability issues
making their way
into production so let's unwrap hybrid
and multi-cloud continuous integration
and continuous delivery
an approach that can help you accelerate
your release cycles
and increase your software reliability
across all your environments
modern ci cd on anthos embraces a
shift-left
approach to development and leverages
declarative templates to manage security
policy not people
this means that issues are addressed
during build and test phase
not in production it allows you to bring
your operations teams together
cutting down on silos and the
proliferation of tools
so let's dive in when we think about the
creation of a ci cd pipeline there are
three different teams that are involved
developers operators and security
engineers
in this model developers have their own
git repository where they store their
application code
that application code can kick off
continuous integration
whenever a developer creates a commit a
change to their application code
a continuous integration tool tests the
code and then creates an
artifact when we're talking about
deploying to kubernetes clusters our
artifacts are container images that will
eventually be pushed to production
once continuous integration creates that
container image
it will store it in container registry
the reference to the recently stored
image will be stored in
another git repository controlled by
your application operations team
we'll call this the deployment repo this
secondary repository holds kubernetes
manifests
which have instructions on how
applications should be configured
in order to manage that configuration we
use a tool called customize
customize packages together the desired
state container image from our container
registry
and the instructions from the kubernetes
manifests and
store it in the deployment repository
this git repository stores the state
that we want to deploy
into our environments the first place
where we store that state
is within the staging branch of the
deployment repository
from that staging branch a continuous
delivery tool
manages the deployment to our staging
environment
where developers can test this
application
with and those consistent platform the
staging environments are more similar to
your production environments
think about problems created with
different tools practices and processes
when testing in the cloud
and then pushing to production in a
totally different environment
when the developers have finished
testing they can tell the operators that
they want to make a push to production
or the operators can control the timing
to push to production
they merge from the staging branch of
the deployment repository into the
master branch
and propagate those changes into
production environment
for our security teams let's talk a
minute about how to secure your
production environments
you also have your own git repository
that is going to store the expected
state of the security policies
things like role-based access control
policies
coders for your applications and
restricting risky behaviors such as the
ability for containers to run as root
how can you do that well one mechanism
we use
is the policy controller which is a part
of config management
because of and those consistent platform
across all of your environments security
teams can customize what policies they
want to run
in what groups of clusters and this is
all done without having to configure it
in each environment that was a quick
overview of modern ci cd on andos
showing how you can increase your
development velocity and produce
safe reliable applications for your
customers
ready to get started check out the
solutions page linked below
and for more anthers content don't
forget to subscribe and
follow the anthos 101 playlist